you don't think there should be a
centralized place for news
there isn't now well
that's what mainstream media is supposed
to represent broken well it's not
whatever
uh what would you call that a place
where people
traditionally said was the like the
legitimate source
of truth no that's what the media was
supposed to represent no
so i that's their that's their big
branding uh
accomplishment it's because that was
never true yeah because if you
here's what happens we remember the
spanish-american war remember the maine
we have to take cuba yellow journalism
willie randolph first right
then record scratch and then we were all
objective
like when did this transition happen
according to people when you were saying
that the kaiser
is uh the worst human being on earth
when you were downplaying uh stalin
and down playing hitler's atrocities
when when you were saying we had to be
in vietnam
at what point wmds when did it change it
never changed you just are better con
artists at a certain point and now the
mask is dropping
yeah but don't you think there's uh at
its best like
investigative journalism can uncover
truth in a way that um
that like reddit uh subreddits can't
you know read it sure i agree at its
best absolutely that's not even dispute
but like don't you think uh
like fake it until you make it is the
right way to do it meaning like
the news no no i meant the new
saying like we dream of doing
of arriving at the truth and reporting
the truth they don't say that
cnn had an advertisement that said this
is an apple we only report facts
that's a lie no that's now and now it's
clear
things have changed and they haven't
changed you're just more uh
you're more aware of chicanery but
okay so the how many people died in iraq
because saddam hussein was about to
launch wmds
who had consequences for this no one
this isn't a minor thing this is
lots of dead people yeah
and also i mean dead people
it's horrible but also the money which
has like we said economic effects that
marianne williamson i think it was it
was had the trump both of them had the
great point that goes
it's like a trillion dollars how many
schools would that build how many roads
did that build even
here why are we building hospitals in
iraq that we destroyed when we could
building hospitals here
it makes no sense it's horrifying so
who's responsible for that like
who um alex jones
so who's responsible for arriving at the
truth
of that of speaking to the money spent
i think this is wars in iraq this is one
of the great things about social media
twitter you have faith in twitter not
just not specifically twitter but yes
social media as a whole what anyone
could be
here's a great another great example
before
if you were talking about police
brutality or these riots
you would have to perceive it in the way
it was framed and presented to nicholas
sandman is another example
uh brianna taylor all these things well
you're not footage of her
um you would have to perceive in the way
that it's edited and presented to you by
the corporate press
now everyone is a video who has video
camera everyone has their perspective
and it's very useful when these
incidents happen where you could see the
same incident from several angles
and you don't need don lemon or chris
wallace to tell me what this means i can
see with my own eyes
yeah i've been very uh pleasantly
surprised
about the power see like people the mob
again gets in the way
they get emotional and they destroy
like the the ability for people to
reason
but you're right that truth is
unobstructed on social media
like if you're if you're careful and
patient you can see the truth yeah
like for example data on coven some of
the best sources
are doctors like if you want to know the
truth about the coronavirus
what's happening is uh there's
follow people on twitter yeah there's
certain people there yes like sourcing
for me versus the cdc and the wa show
it's
that's that's fast i mean it's well it's
kind of anarchy right it's yes it is
it's anarchy yes i mean well there's
some
censorship and all that kind of stuff
you have censorship under anarchy in the
sense that you're talking about like
people be
kicked off on twitter that's a drawing
can take somebody okay
so yeah i mean it's a private company
private company
most people wouldn't say twitter's
working but they that's probably because
they take for granted
how well it's working and they're just
complaining about the small part of it
that's broken right
okay another question about don't you
feel better
no by the way i mean i had a personal
gripe with the situation about the um
not a personal gripe but i felt overly
emotional
about um the possibility that there will
be
some of donald trump messing with the
election process
but you made me feel better like saying
like he if he had a bunch of
opportunities
to um to do what like
to do what i would have done if i was a
dictator i would um
the first time those rides over george
floyd howard instituted
um martial law do you know what i
remember very vividly
is after 9 11 and everyone was waiting
for george bush to give his speech
and he had 98 approval rating and i
remember very vividly because
if he had said we're suspending the
constitution
everyone had cheered for him like he
couldn't get enough support at that time
and he didn't do it
and i can't say anything really good
about george w bush i'm not a fan of his
to say the least
so i think you and i and you know other
people who are familiar with you know
uh totalitarian regimes to some extent
from our ancestry or whatever from
research
should always be the ones freaking out
and warning
but we should also be aware of we got a
ways to go
before it's hitler and thankfully
uh there are a lot of dominoes that have
to fall into place before hitler it's
like the game secret hitler it's a board
game
before hitler becomes hitler like it's
not
e especially in america there's lots of
things that have to happen
before you really get to that point i
mean fdr was for all intents and
purposes of dictator
but even then the worst you could say
and this is not something that you take
lightly
was internment of japanese citizens but
they weren't murdered
uh they weren't you know you know under
lock and key in the sense of like in
cells
so things could have gotten a lot worse
for him
you